hey guys today i'm going to talk about
10 hygiene rules that you should never
ever break hygiene is extremely
important because it is taking care of
your body yourself and you only have one
house for your soul to live in so you
better take good care of it
now if you follow these 10 rules you
will always make good first impressions
you will be healthier keeping away
diseases you will smell good look good
and no one will talk bad behind your
back about your hygiene so let's not
waste any more time let's get to the
video
[Music]
alright guys we have 10 areas to cover
when it comes to hygiene dental hair
nails
facial skin body skin
feet
hands
ears and nose
lips
and eyes
let's start with number one
you know you only have the teeth that
you have you don't get more throughout
life
so that's why i don't understand why
guys don't take care of their teeth
because nothing beats healthy good
looking white teeth you have to brush
your teeth twice a day when you wake up
in the morning and before you go to bed
at night and then brush them in the
middle of the day as well and remember
don't just go and brush your teeth
because oral hygiene includes your gums
and your tongue
and don't forget to floss to get rid of
all the gunk in between your teeth
now by hair i'm talking about all the
hair on your head and also
on your face your beard it has to be
clean at all times no dandruff no oily
dirty looking hair now that is the one
extreme the other extreme is where you
wash it too much where it becomes dry
and dull so the rule is to wash your
hair and beard every two to three days
the shampoo and softener you need to use
for the strong hard hair of your beard
is different than the shampoo and
conditioner for your hair on your head
at this moment i started to use beard
brand yes that is the brand name beard
brand
anyway i started to use their products
because it is good quality it works and
it's not just for your beer they have
products for your hair and your whole
body as well
now apart from keeping your hair clean
you also need to keep it styled
so if you use these products good
quality products it will help your beard
hair your hair on your head as well to
feel soft and more moisturized so you
will be able to style it better but if
you have hair that's a little bit of a a
problem you know very frizzy and it's
difficult to control it or very thin
hair then you can also use the sea salt
spray right after you get out of the
shower
there are many guys who don't take care
of their nails and that is one of the
first signs most women look at to see if
their hygiene is good or not that's
exactly what my wife did as well she
only told me that later now when i talk
about nails i'm not just talking about
your hands but also your toes always
make sure they are short and clean never
allow them to become long yellow and
dirty
[Music]
man
your face represents you people look at
it all the time when they talk to you so
you have to take care of it if you have
blackheads get rid of them if you have
pimples get rid of them if you have hair
on your nose or on your upper cheekbones
get rid of them and then to have clear
skin you can't use the same soap that
you use to wash your body towards your
face because the skin
is different
i use geology which is amazing because
they customize your products to take
care of your unique skin concerns
you just go to their website
[Music]
answer a few questions about your skin's
condition
[Music]
then they put the ingredients together
and send it directly to your house easy
as that then you just use the skincare
routine in the morning and at night
first you wash it
[Applause]
[Music]
then you use the daytime moisturizer or
the nighttime moisturizer depending on
the time of day
[Music]
you know sometimes when i get out of the
house and i meet guys i can see when
guys don't really take care of their
body
you can see that their skin is kind of
flaky and dry
use a body moisturizer to make sure your
skin gets what it needs to look healthy
now just very quick before i forget if
it's the first time that you're here and
if you like this video so far chances
are you'll probably like the other
videos on my channel as well so remember
to subscribe i would really love the
support let's move on to the next one
[Music]
you know whenever you go to certain
places where guys wear sandals or
flip-flops and you look at it and it
looks kind of disgusting right it's like
flaky there's like cracks and i already
talked about the toenails but you also
need to take care of your feet take a
look at your own feet what does the skin
look like is it dry peeling off or is it
in a good condition take care of it by
putting on moisturizer now if you're one
of those guys who are struggling with
cracked heels all the time and you don't
know why one of the reasons is because
you're not wearing your shoes enough you
choose more
in the direction of sandals and
flip-flops and that's why you need to
use shoes a lot more and then put it on
the right cream i'll add it for in the
video description so you can check it
out
now the tips for the hands are mostly
the same tips that i gave for the feet
for some reason there are some guys it
depends on what job you do right what
you do with your hands but as a lot of
guys when you when you greet them their
hands kind of feel like sandpaper so
it's flaky it's dry and they don't take
care of it no woman will like it when
you want to touch them with sand paper
hands so use a moisturizer and take care
of your hands
your ears clean right now
how about your nose some of you are like
i don't know well that is exactly the
problem you should know if they are
clean or not never pick your nose in
public before you start your day blow
your nose then look in the mirror and
make sure there are no hairs creeping
out of it and if there are get rid of
them then take your ears as well this
mostly happens with older men they start
to get these hair scooping out of their
ears not everyone but some men if that's
you take care of it
[Music]
if your lips are dry don't just ignore
it do something about it if i go out
fishing or camping it sometimes get dry
and the best thing to get it back to
normal is zambak this is a south african
thing but it works
[Music]
you know eyes
are the window to the soul that sounds
very cheesy and that's what most people
say but in a sense it is true because
that's where people look when they talk
to you they look at you into your eyes
to connect with you so why don't you
take care of your eyes this includes
your eyebrows the skin around your eyes
and the eye itself first of all if you
have a unibrow thing going on get rid of
the hair between your eyebrows and then
if you have fuzzy crazy eyebrows that
grows in all kinds of directions just
take a tweezer and pluck some of the
crazy hairs out never wax it or squeeze
them out to make a thin line because
that fits in more with women
then if you don't get good quality sleep
so you get these dark circles under your
eyes or your your eyeballs are red if
that's a big problem for you check out
these videos here and it will help you
i'll see you there before you go always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys